die schlimmen ereignisse in der ukraine
und der angriffskrieg von wladimir putin
und von russland auf das ukrainische
volk die sind nicht nur
verheerend in der ukraine
und sie stellen eine belastung für ganz
europa dar sondern sie werfen natürlich
auch in deutschland viele neue fragen
auf und eine der fragen ist brauchen wir
die wehrpflicht oder müssen wir auch in
deutschland
wieder die wehrpflicht einführen und ich
bin der meinung wir brauchen nicht eine
wehrpflicht wie wir sie früher
kennengelernt haben aber wir brauchen
eine allgemeine dienstpflicht oder ein
gesellschafts jahr in deutschland das
für männer und das für frauen
gleichermaßen gilt jeder junge mensch
der sollte nach der schule entweder zur
bundeswehr gehen der sollte wie früher
beim zivildienst vielleicht in ein
pflegeheim gehen der sollte in eine
einrichtung gehen da wo menschen mit
behinderung wird menschen mit
behinderung geholfen wird wo es ihnen
ermöglicht wird ins alltagsleben im
alltagsleben fuß zu fassen es kann sein
dass es gut ist dass menschen in eine
erziehungsanstalt gehen es gibt ganz
viele soziale einrichtungen im land in
denen gerade junge menschen gebraucht
werden und wo es auch gut ist dass junge
menschen mal rauskommen aus dem was sie
sonst so kenne das sie mit sozialen
problemen konfrontiert werden und
deswegen bin ich dafür wir brauchen mehr
staatsbürger und wir brauchen weniger
ich bürger in deutschland und es kann
für den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
enorm hilfreich sein wenn menschen nach
dem schulabschluss ein gesellschafts
jahr machen und etwas im sozialbereich
tun oder auch zur bundeswehr gehen wir
brauchen weniger ich bürger wir brauchen
mehr staatsbürger das höre ich in
deutschland in der korona pandemie seit
zwei jahren in dauerschleife ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich möchte dass der
ukraine geholfen wird und zwar zu dem
höchst möglichen maße ich bewundere
helmig der heute in der runde ist wie
sehr er kämpft für sein land und auch
ich will dass deutschland hilft
sanktionen gehören dazu aber jetzt schon
wieder dass die jungen leute schon
wieder entscheidet der staat was junge
leute in deutschland machen sollen das
reicht nicht ja aber auch nicht ich
würde die fragen direkt an hellenic
schicken dass es ihrem land jetzt hilft
stellen wir in deutschland ein
gesellschafts jahr machen und nach der
korona pandemie wieder jungen menschen
vorschreiben was sie jetzt karabey zu
tun haben oder wie sehen war der sei um
das ist aber an herrn nicht glaube dass
der gedanke schon richtig ist das denn
doch bloß gerade ausgedrückt hat denn
wir brauchen schon wir haben gesehen
also der staat hat einen wert und das
erleben wir ihn ohne staat haben wir
viele jahrzehnte verbringen müssen ohne
den staat und den wert dieses staates zu
erkennen was das auch für jeden
einzelnen bürger bedeutet das hat man
das sieht man jetzt in der ukraine man
kämpft ja nicht nur für für den
wohnblock wurde für das soll sondern
auch für diesen ukrainische staat weil
wenn es ihn nicht geben sollte dann ist
das alles weg dann kann man alles
vergessen kann man den wohlstand nicht
mehr haben dann kann man die sprache
vergessen das alles wird verschwinden
deswegen nicht kann durchaus diese
meinung teilen ich bürger ist wichtig
freiheit wie sie die bin auch freiheit
aber neben der freiheit ist die
staatlichkeit aus unserer sicht genauso
zentral ich war früher exakt derselben
meinung wie sie ich habe dafür auch
mehrfach geschrieben weil mir das sehr
einleuchtend erschienen heute bin ich
nicht mehr dieser meinung jedenfalls
nicht mehr vollständig weil ich glaube
dass ein soziales pflichtjahr für junge
leute im sozialen bereich den druck auf
die gehälter die niedrigen gehälter für
die leute die dort fest arbeiten noch
verstärken wird wenn die die
krankenhäuser die soziale einrichtungen
quasi kostenfrei junge leute kriegen
bedeutet das dass die leute die dort
arbeiten in keine richtung argumente
mehr haben um ihre gehälter zu
verbessern ich glaube um es kurz zu
machen
dass wir die werbung
die lampen überzeugt dass es richtig war
die wehrpflicht hat eine große
politische tradition nämlich das kann
man heute kaum mehr sagen ohne falsch
verstanden zu werden das war als sie
geschaffen wurde wurde vom milizsystem
gekauft da
milizionäre abstand genommen und wurde
eine volksarmee eingeführt die hat
beispielsweise dazu beigetragen napoleon
aus aus aus aus mittel und osteuropa zu
vertreiben nur so war das mögliche sind
preußen eingeführt worden und war eine
politische errungenschaft und diese
politische errungenschaft dass alle sich
für den staat und seine sicherheit
einzusetzen haben ist leichtfertig von
der cdu aufgegeben worden da haben viele
schon damals daran gezweifelt und heute
sind die zweifel noch viel größer
geworden die bundeswehr hatte damals als
es die wehrpflicht noch gab doppelt so
viele soldaten wie sie heute hat und
heute mangels ja nicht nur an gerät es
mangelt auch an menschen die in der
bundeswehr dienen und deshalb ich stimme
ihnen also partiell zu über den rest
müsste man auch reden wehrpflicht wieder
her aber da da will ich dann will ich
mal widersprechen weil wir haben ja kein
problem die ganz dass die ganz vielen
offenen stellen die es ja im gerade im
pflegebereich gibt zu besetzen also es
würde ja nicht dazu führen wenn jetzt
ein junger mensch in bereichen der zahlt
wenn es an wenn jetzt ein junger mensch
im bereich der pflege hilft wird das nie
dazu führen dass eine ausgebildete
pflegekraft keinen job bekommt sondern
das gegenteil ist der fall wir haben ja
hunderttausende offene stellen schon
klar und ein junger mensch der nach der
schule beispielsweise bei der pflege
hilft der macht ja nicht genau das was
eine ausgebildete pfleger macht das darf
der ja gar nicht deswegen kann man das
auch nicht so vergleichen mir geht es
eher darum dass man einfach mal mit
problemen dieses landes konfrontiert
wird dass junge menschen die vielleicht
sonst behütet aufwachsen danach ein
studium machen in einem büro sitzen im
glaskasten danach ihren porsche nach
hause fahren dass die auch einen anderen
bereich mal sehen und auch mit anderen
menschen zusammen kommen mit denen sie
sonst vielleicht nie zusammen kommen
würden und das ist für den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt ganz
ganz wichtig und es gibt im land so viel
bedarf an sozialen tätigkeiten dass das
argument da wird kann vielleicht eine
pflegekraft dann nicht mehr arbeiten
einfach nicht gilt